where it starts to get a bit funky is
where you mix these things together okay
so it's him
let's think about let's think about this
we'll go with X months one let's add X
plus one okay
so we're adding two functions together
there's a couple of ways to go about
this I can do the algebraic route okay
and that's I will do that in a second
okay but I want to try an appeal to the
visuals if I can because that's a very
powerful way to understand things okay
so I'm gonna draw my graph we're gonna
take a bit of a shortcut because I
already know what the absolute value of
x -1 looks like it looks like this so
it's just like the absolute value of x
but it's being moved over a little bit
okay so because these this graph I'm
back to drawer is not my final graph I'm
gonna put that in a lighter color so if
you can maybe just lightly pencil it in
here it is okay so there is the absolute
value of x one okay both parts of it
okay how is the absolute value of x plus
1 different okay well instead of
starting with X minus 1 and then bounce
I'm gonna stop with X plus 1 which kind
of looks like this right and then that
bounces so in fact it's gonna look like
this you can see it's the absolute value
of x pence moon that way instead of that
way okay so far so good
okay now keep in mind right I've got
here two branches of this one with
different equations and two branches of
this one with different equations okay
so in fact this is where I'm gonna put
in my property equations now this one's
X minus 1 sorry this one's X minus 1
this is 1 minus X not this one let's
this equation here it's just that much
right hand side that's X plus 1 right
and then on the other side I've got
minus X minus 1 right it's going down
and what if you get here negative 1 okay
so now to add these two together I think
I've got all of these different cases to
think together right let's do this
piece by piece
okay we know that this intercept here is
negative one in this is one okay so for
the case where x equals negative one
this graph will be equal to zero see
that what will this graph be equal to
you can even see it can't you because
I've drawn it reasonably accurately what
should this value up here be equal to
should be positive two right look
there's one and then two yes so 0 1 2 so
much it's 2 here right now if I go to 0
this graph plus this graph 0 plus 2 is
equal to 2 isn't it so when I add these
two graphs together the sum of these two
graphs will be here that makes sense I
can replay the same thing over here
watch I'm adding this green graph and
this green graph right this one's equal
to 0 down here and it's equal to well
it's symmetrical should also equal to
right so I'm going through that point
now I'm just going to stop for a second
cuz you like huh
what just happened let me just verify
this for you just with the numbers when
X is equal to negative 1
what's this thing well Y is equal to the
absolute value of minus 1 so negative 1
minus 1 plus C that I just substituted
in negative 1 that's all I'm doing okay
so what happens here what's inside the
absolute value negative 2 what's inside
this step absolute guys zero and the
absolute value of finger 2 is sure
enough it's just two like I expected and
I can replay this again if I substitute
x equals positive 1 I'll still get 2
okay all right now think with me we'll
do it visually and then we'll do it
algebraically what's happening in this
middle section between here and here one
graph is going down it's decreasing the
other graph is increasing and one is
decreasing at exactly the same rate that
the other one is increasing okay so let
me give you a picture okay you remember
the arms input and output valves for our
tank of water before right and somebody
something's coming up so this looks like
is I've got like whiteboard markers okay
and I put them into a box and as soon as
I put one in right I'm increasing
someone else takes it out there
decreases right and then I put the next
one in increase and then at the same
time someone takes one out so what's
happening to the amount of whiteboard
markers in my box it's staying the same
every one I put in someone takes one out
every time this graph goes down and this
graph goes up so the net effect is no
change which is why if I started at two
I'll stay at two no sure what just
happened I'm gonna do it again
algebraically because you already know
stay with me
you know what the equation of this
branching here is right let me write in
close so just so you can see it 1 minus
X right 1 minus x going down that way
what's the equation at this one here
it's X plus 1 going up right well in
this little section here in this domain
if I add this 1 minus X and X plus 1 the
X's cancel and all you get left with is
2 so the equation of my new middle
section is y equals 2 which of course
you know is a horizontal one all right
now again visually then algebraically
what would you expect is happening over
here with my hand side don't shout it
out think with me because some of you
already have it I think I've seen this
kinda crabs are full let's go back to my
whiteboard marker example right there's
not a decrease in an increase anymore
it's happening over here this is
increasing and this is increasing so
it's like two of us including whiteboard
markers in right so not only should I
expect it to increase what rate should I
expect it to increase that twice as fast
right which as a gradient would be two
because the great needed this is one and
the gradient is one all right so that's
the visual watch it happen algebraically
right X plus 1 X minus 1 plus 1 and
negative 1
they cancel out or you get left with is
X plus X which is two masses now the
great thing about this you see this if
I've drawn it actually if you get a rule
on let's see how well I've done I should
be able to bring these back well always
a bit off right away it should be going
through the origin
just like 2x would normally right except
I'm in a restricted domain only
equal to 2x on this side okay now before
I do anything look at the symmetry of
this thing I'm not even gonna do any
like argument what do you think's
happening on the left-hand side same
thing but in Reverse what do you think
it's equation is negative 2x right and
how can you tell that algebraically you
take these two guys right this positive
1 and this negative 1 will cancel just
like these ones do and all I'll be left
with is negative X minus X which is
minus suing us